el triángulo n prima es la imagen de n
después de aplicarle una potencia bueno
aquí tengo al triángulo n prima en color
rosa y el triángulo n en color azul cuál
es el centro de la noticia nos dan
varias opciones el punto a al punto b en
el punto c en el punto de cuál de éstos
es el centro de la noticia pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar la respuesta
bueno vamos a resolverlo de dos formas
distintas
la primera es pensar en la razón de
potencia en nuestra n original observa
este lado tiene una longitud de dos
unidades y cuando se le aplica la
noticia terminamos con una longitud de 4
unidades pasamos de 2 a 4 por lo tanto
la razón de motes ya parece ser de 2
2 x 2 es 4 ahora como nos ayudan a
encontrar el centro de la noticia
bueno una forma de pensarlo es tomar dos
puntos cualesquiera que sean
correspondientes supongamos que tomamos
este punto y este otro entonces la
imagen de este punto en n prima estará
tan lejos del centro de potencia como el
resultado de la razón de potencia por la
distancia a la que se encuentra el punto
original por ejemplo en este caso
sabemos que la razón de moto2 por lo
tanto este punto en n prima estará al
doble de distancia de nuestro centro de
motes ya que lo que estará nuestro punto
original en n bueno inmediatamente
puedes ver que van en la misma dirección
por lo tanto si dibujamos una recta que
conecta estos dos puntos sólo existe un
punto que sea con lineal a la recta que
estoy dibujando
es la opción de así que parece que este
es nuestro centro de potencia pero
podemos verificar lo observa que en este
primer punto en el triángulo original n
cambia dos unidades en equis y tres
unidades en que ahora si quieres ir del
centro de potencia al punto
correspondiente pero en la imagen en el
triángulo n prima entonces tendremos que
ir el doble de lejos su cambio en x será
de 4 unidades y tu cambio
james será de 6 unidades incluso puedes
ver el teorema de pitágoras para
calcular esta distancia y después la
otra distancia completa y verás que es
el doble por lo tanto puedes ver que el
punto correspondiente en la imagen está
el doble de lejos del centro de la
noticia hay dos formas de encontrar el
centro de la noticia si conectas los
puntos correspondientes el centro de
murcia estará en la misma recta que pasa
por estos dos puntos y la segunda forma
es observando que la imagen debe de
estar distanciada del centro de murcia
lo que
vale la razón de potencia en este caso
vemos que esta distancia del centro de
potencia el doble de lo que está el
punto de la figura original hemos
terminado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo